mucho de lo que aprenderán en ecuaciones
diferenciales es en realidad una
cantidad impresionante de bolsas con
trucos y en este vídeo les voy a mostrar
uno de ellos es muy práctico y más allá
de esto bueno siempre es bueno cuando
algún día se conviertan en matemáticos o
físicos y se encuentren con un problema
sin resolver
uno de estos trucos que a lo mejor
parecerán muy sencillos les pueden
servir para resolver este tipo de
problemas y bueno si están llevando un
curso de ecuaciones diferenciales para
lo que les va a servir pues es a
resolver su examen así que aprendamos el
truco de los factores integrantes
digamos que tenemos una ecuación
diferencial 3x y más y voy a tratar de
escribir lo más nítido posible 3x yemas
y cuadrada y más
x cuadrada más que será más xy por prima
la derivada de ye respecto de x y lo
igual vamos a hacer así que ya que hemos
repasado esto en vídeos anteriores
siempre que tenemos una ecuación de esta
forma como que nos interesa a ver si es
una ecuación exacta verdad decimos bueno
esto luce como como una ecuación
diferencial exacta consume suena y demás
como lo demostramos bueno derivamos la
primera parte respecto de y que es
nuestra función m y vemos si esto es
igual
bueno derivamos respecto de nuestra
función m que es 3x yemas de cuadrada y
esa derivada es 3 x + 2 y ahora
derivemos esta función que es nuestra
función n vamos a derivar lo respecto de
x ok entonces derivamos en el respecto
de xy nos queda 2x
y esto para que sea una ecuación
diferencial exacta tendrían que ser
iguales verdad pero este no es el caso
aquí vemos sólo observando estas dos que
no son iguales por lo tanto no puede ser
una ecuación diferencial exacta de esta
forma sin embargo sin embargo qué
pasaría si hubiese algún factor o alguna
alguna función que pudiésemos
multiplicar en ambos lados de la
ecuación para convertirla en una
ecuación diferencial exacta así que
vamos a proponer una función que vamos a
llamar new y vamos a multiplicar la
ecuación diferencial de ambos lados por
esta función new que no no sabemos cuál
es y vamos a ver si podemos volverla una
ecuación exacta muy bien entonces al
multiplicar de ambos lados por un amigo
que en principio puede ser una función
de xy de ahí yo solo la voy a proponer
por ahora que sea una función que
depende exclusivamente de x ok entonces
ustedes pueden proponer que sea una
función que dependa de ella y lo podrán
resolver haganlo como ejercicio
si lo hicieran una función general que
depende de xy de ye se vuelve muy
complicado así que vamos a proponer que
es una función que depende de x new de x
si multiplicamos del lado izquierdo nos
queda mide x x 3 x + y al cuadrado y
ahora más me de x x x x cuadrada más xy
que multiplica a prima y esto igual a 0
por mil que es cero porque lo que quiero
que quede claro es que si multiplique
del lado derecho por un año pero como
multiplique por cero pues da lo mismo
verdad entonces este mide x cuando lo
multiplicamos nuestro objetivo es ver si
podemos llevarlo a una ecuación exacta
ok entonces ahora nuestra función m es
esto que estoy subrayando de rosa ok y
esta otra que voy a subrayar ahora
es nuestra función n así que la derivada
de esto respecto de qué es
vamos a ver bueno si estamos tomando la
parcial respecto del 'new de x es una
constante así que no no la derivamos
sale entonces tomamos la parcial
respecto de iu y todo lo que depende de
x es una constante así que finalmente
voy a escribirlo la parcial respecto de
de esto es mu de x por la derivada de
este paréntesis respecto de y que es 13
x + 2
ok esto es la parcial de esta nueva
función respecto de ella y cuál es la
parcial respecto de x de esta nueva
función aquí vamos a usar la regla del
producto así que tomamos la derivada de
muse respecto de x que ya no es una
constante porque ahora derivamos
respecto de x así que la derivada de miu
de x respecto de x bueno pues es la new
prima de x
y multiplicamos por ahorita ahorita que
recuerdo mío es como un sonido ruso para
la letra griega verdad que estamos
escribiendo pero bueno ese era una nota
multiplicamos esta mi prima por equis
cuadrada más equis y le sumamos mide
equis y la derivada de este factor que
está en el paréntesis respecto de x que
es 2x más y todo esto lo resolvimos
utilizando la regla del producto y
entonces al multiplicar por mil
obtenemos esta relación de las derivadas
parciales que nos interesan y queremos
hacer una igualdad de estas dos
expresiones para que sea exacta y así
vamos a tener que ver cómo es nuestra
función misma ok vamos a ver de este
lado tenemos que muse de x multiplica
3 x 2 y ahora el factor que tenemos con
mide x del lado derecho lo vamos a
restar de ambos lados y tenemos menos
mide x
2x es decir el del lado derecho lo
pasamos del lado izquierdo
restando ok ahora qué es lo que nos
queda del lado derecho vamos a
escribirlo con amarillo sale nos queda
mi prima de x x x cuadrada más xy vamos
a escribir lo mío prima de x x x
cuadrada más xy muy bien ahora vamos a
simplificar del lado izquierdo tenemos
newport
de x perdón por 3 x 2
esto es factor izando mi x y restamos 2
x menos ok y esto va a ser igual a mi
prima de x x x cuadrada más x que es
simplemente lo que teníamos arriba muy
bien
entonces simplificamos lo que tenemos en
el paréntesis y nos queda mide x x 3 x 2
x verdad es agrupando las x y nos queda
x y luego 2 y menos es simplemente y y
esto es igual a mi prima de x que
simplificamos de este lado al factorizar
una x del lado derecho
muy bien factor izamos una x y que nos
queda x que multiplica
a x más muy bien entonces ahora ya
tenemos una nueva ex 3 expresión y
podemos simplificar dividiendo de ambos
lados de la igualdad por x + y entonces
este x + 10 se cancela de ambos lados
suponiendo que x + es distinto de 0 así
que me dé x es igual a mi prima de x x x
verdad simplemente nos quedó mi prima de
x por x y ahora así funciona mi cerebro
me gusta reescribir es también prima de
x en su forma con un operador donde en
su lugar de escribir mi prima de x voy a
poner de mi respecto de x entonces
reescribo nada más voy a reescribir mi
de x es igual a derivada de mí respecto
de x de su forma con operador y
multiplicó por una x y esto en realidad
es una ecuación diferencial separables y
si se dan cuenta entonces
resolver quién es mío que es nuestro
factor integrante al resolver la
ecuación diferencial así que si pongo
mide x / x esto será igual a la derivada
de mí respecto de x
ahora vamos a dividir ambos lados por
mide x y del lado izquierdo tenemos 1 /
x igual a
uno entre mil uno entre mil que es mi de
equis pero sólo voy a poner uno entre
mil por demi de equis ok ahora nos
seguimos del lado derecho y
multiplicamos por ambos lados por b x y
nos queda uno entre x de x igual a uno
entre mil de miu que si integramos de
ambos lados de este de esta expresión
tendremos el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de x igual a logaritmo natural
de muse etcétera pero debe quedar claro
que x es igual a mí o correcto son
idénticas estas expresiones simplemente
x toma el valor o el papel de miu del
lado derecho entonces lo que nos dice es
que mide x es igual
o que me es igual a x como quieran así
que ya tenemos nuestro factor integrante
y si lo desean bueno podemos tomarla
a la primitiva pero bueno solo por mirar
esta expresión sabemos que mío es igual
a equis porque ambos lados son
completamente en lo mismo de todas
formas ahora tenemos nuestro factor
integrante pero ya me estoy quedando sin
tiempo así que en el siguiente vídeo
vamos a multiplicar la ecuación
diferencial original y la vamos a hacer
exacta luego lo resolvemos pero ya lo
veremos en el próximo vídeo